foreign
thank you very much for coming tonight's
meeting of planning committees
my name's Andy crumpy we'll be chairing
tonight's meeting before we start
there's a little bit of Hair Skin pin
please could we make sure our phones are
either on a silent or Switched Off
because there's nothing worse than a
speaker being interrupted by the sounds
of Andy Pandy The Great Escape or
anything other tune whatever tune you've
got and I'll turn mine off just to make
sure as well
as a parent my children's often say do
as I say not as I do but on this case
I'll try and not adhere to that also
it might be very very tempting to
interrupt a speaker but please could you
give them the courtesy of not
interrupting and the only people allowed
to speak are the people on the
registered list
so please could you not interrupt
however attempting it may be
even if it's me please don't interrupt
I'd like to introduce the top table
Olivia Queen committee services
Legal Services
good evening my name is Dale Barker I'm
a planning manager in my role as an
impartial advisor to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing so I'm Bound by the code of
professional conduct of the rtpi
planning committee members are not bound
by the case officer's recommendation or
by any oral advice we may give
Anthony Young Senior planner
sorry Allison Willis senior planner
very much
move on to the first item on the agenda
which is apologies for absence chair
apologies from councilor parry and
councilor O'Donnell
colleges I will be leaving at 7 30
. thank you very much
disclosures of Interest catch the
building as an orbit tenant I have to
declare that and also I have received
documentation with regards to the
number five of the
if you want the number eight nineteen
zero zero zero five out and she will be
speaking about you yeah yeah
um gentlemen can you come okay
Mike uh will you be speaking you know
you're okay you're not you won't be
withdrawn no I won't be saying anything
interest whatsoever in it and therefore
I will be as a member of the committee
yeah you so you basically come to the
committee with an open mind very good
man that was the phrase we were looking
for
thank you chairman um the first
application uh for Willett House uh in
wellsborn I'm a member of wellsborn
Parish Council um this came to the
council a long time ago I always abstain
when it's on for the other patch so I
come to this with an open mind and I'm
happy to sit on the committee
thank you very much
funds I'm sorry we cut you off that well
yes I've had correspondence on the
second one
0005 yeah I think I think we all offer
yeah thank you connect that please
Olivia
didn't have that one
okay thank you
I'm sure you'll join join with us later
counselor site the radio contribution
thank you right uh
for February okay so Brian I'll be with
us today sorry are you happy that we saw
in the meeting and minutes of the 6th of
February
oh good man thank you
now you've got proposed in a second of
council Barnes and Council fielding and
all those in fiber
thank you
yeah happy to
sign those later
we'll now move to the first item on the
agenda which is application
18-00977 if you willit house stroke
garages wallet Garden St Peters Road
Hastings Road Wells law and
stratford-upon-avon demolition of
properties of
at willit house
Etc Anthony is our presenting officer
thank you chair so the first slide up is
an image of
wellsborn as it sits in the landscape
and you can see the black dot in the
middle so it's a very Central
Development to the to to the settlement
and here we have the three red edges
um so the the development is spread over
three sites and the main site is what's
referred to as Willits will it Gardens
which is a sheltered housing scheme
built circa 1960 and the small smaller
sites are um parking courts of the same
era and this is all for Demolition and
for redevelopment
and here we have the red Edge again and
next to that is the proposed layout so
as you can see the large will it Garden
site is taking the bulk of the
development and the smaller sites are
three three dwellings in forms of
terraces uh on the old garage parking
sites
the purple line here just on the
left-hand plan denotes the extent of the
conservation area and just out of um
planned site there where I'm moving the
cursor there are two listed buildings
so just to give members a sample of the
um the style of housing that's to be
demolished there we see uh will it
Gardens along left hand side of the
slide and the photographs of the um the
the the the the garages to be demolished
and I thought I'd include the accesses
to those Gary sites so it gives members
a a consent contextual idea of where
they where they're sitting within the
estate
um some Street Scene views
um so they're quite simple simple
informant detailing and so appropriate
to the the style of development there
dating as I say from the 60s so fairly
plain and simple
and there we go with a a larger
scale plans with a bit of a contemporary
twist too that
and here we have a street scene so
existing at the top and you can just see
the the Bungalows just receding there
into the background
of Willett Gardens and they will be
replaced by the proposed development so
members can see how they will sit within
the street scene and the flats are just
out just just through filtered views
there through that foliage and you can
see the the new new houses are on on the
left and as I say going down the right
hand side
um so the the recommendation is to
approve members subject to conditions
and subject to a section 106 for various
contributions and subject to an update
um which uh because of the NDP
requirements uh the NDP was adopted
during the course of considering this
application and um any NDP uh policy ww8
requires a proportion of the houses to
be
Bungalows and that amounts to two
Bungalows which have now been
incorporated into the layout and they
will be given priority for elderly and
those with disabilities and it's just to
make members aware that that will be
reflected in the section 106 and so that
that those those individuals are
prioritized thank you chair
all right thank you Anthony
um
whilst born Parish Council
were due to speak however they're not
able to attend they've asked me to read
it I guess
slide email here small email
uh it is unfortunate that due to
unforeseen circumstances the price
Council will not be able to attend the
East area planning community site and
what like it known to the community that
we would have asked councilor party to
represent the Paris council's opinion on
its behalf
but that she's also otherwise engaged
Council sends apologies to the committee
for not being able to attend
and represent itself on this occasion so
if we could note that please
now we'll move on to our first Speaker
which is Stephanie Hawkins please
good evening you've got three minutes
would you like a warning with about 30
seconds to go or have you timed it to
Perfection I think it's time
all right we'll look forward to that
Lenovo I'll be yeah
thank you very much by the way when
you're ready
thank you chair members members of
planning committee thank you for the
opportunity
planner at Barton Wilmore I'm here on
behalf of the applicant orbit and
speaking support of the application for
the Redevelopment of Willett House and
garages at St Peters Road and Hastings
road to provide 35 new homes
will it house is an outdated sheltered
Housing Development comprising small
properties that are difficult to let and
not economically viable to reconfigure
or update especially with Orbit's new
Extra Care scheme at Eddington Lodge the
garages do not cater for modern vehicles
and are underused orbit seat to
revitalize these Brownfield sites that
are located within a residential area of
wellsborn provide a range of new homes
and improve housing choice in the local
area and contribute to a balanced and
sustainable community
the application was submitted following
pre-application consultation with your
officers the parish council local
community and other key stakeholders
orbit have continued to work positively
with your officers and other
stakeholders through the application
process responding to matters raised
this includes an amendment to the scheme
to include bungalows
the pose Redevelopment does not increase
a number of homes or floor space on the
sites the sites can comfortably
accommodate 35 new homes in keeping with
the character of the area safeguarding
the living conditions of occupiers and
adjacent residents and delivering
site-specific requirements including
parking for each new home and visitors
taking account of your emergent emerging
development standards SPD
through the application process orbit
has worked with statutory consultes to
address all concerns raised including
concerns of the highways Authority lead
local flood Authority and waste and
recycling officer as a result the
application is before you with no
objections from any statutory consultee
orbit will continue constructive
dialogue in bringing forward the
proposed development including with
residents adjacent to the sites to
ensure any disruption during the
construction process is managed
overall orbit are committed to
revitalizing these sites to improve the
neighborhood and contribute to a
thriving Community orbit deliver
well-built quality homes that are energy
efficient and future-proofed every place
orbit creates is designed for Safety and
Security and he's green with Landscaping
appropriate to the location
in conclusion The Proposal before you
represent a high quality sustainable
development it occurs with the
development plan and there are no
objections from statutory consultees it
is therefore respectfully requested that
members follow the recommendations put
forward by their case officer and
approve the application thank you
done you've passed the test thank you
any questions cancer balance and cancer
assignment councilor Ken although the
board member in the parish aren't here
he says they both said over development
of the site
is a mix of houses on the side of it
what's the what in your eyes is the
number per hectare or
it's on three sides it is it is on three
sites it doesn't actually increase the
number of dwellings it's actually a net
loss of one unit
um and the floor space actually isn't
increased at all so in terms of the
built form across those sites it
actually doesn't over develop it yeah
and the mix did you on the mix as well
the mix is a series of one two three and
four bedroom dwellings majority being
two to three bed thank you
just signed yeah
what I can't see from your presentation
or from the office's presentation is
where people are going to park their
cars
can you Enlighten us there please
I can meet the development requirement
standards SPD there's one parking space
for one bed dwellings these are on in
curtainage parking spaces which is on
the layout that we've provided there's
two parking spaces for two and three bed
dwellings and there's four parking
spaces for four bed dwellings the
visitor parking is in accordance with
standards there's a total requirement
for seven the SPD allows that to be in
Courtyards in curtainage of certain
dwellings and on Street we've got six
allocated visitor parking spaces plus
we've got another six properties that
have additional parking on that required
and we have the ability for on-street
parking
okay second question chairman the parish
council
conclude their objection by saying there
is still no green open space allocation
on that drawing that we saw that Mr
Young put up for his presentation there
are some green areas
would that be open space
there's can you can you clarify where
the open space will be there's
Landscaping there isn't actually a
requirement for public open space in
this instance because there is not a net
increase in dwellings
pretty good
thank you councilor Kendall thank you
chairman
good evening um just a couple of
questions
on the numbers basically I just want to
try and clarify in my mind what what
you're proposing here
um
in terms of what is present there will
it Gardens Willett House that's an uh
sheltered Care Facility what was the
occupancy of of that
when it was operated I know it's close
to how people are moving out now just
bear with me it's all right
there is a total of 36 dwellings on it
um 32 one bed and four um the two bed
okay and what you only because you
mentioned it and so it's not strictly
part of the application but obviously in
terms of providing shelter care in Wells
born as the village as a whole you've
mentioned that obviously there's the
move from with its house and presumably
you're trying to move people from that
to the new Edington Lodge
um am I right it's really a question for
the African
is they have decanted and moved out
residents some have gone to Essington
Lodge not all have it's been a choice of
people where they wanted to go and some
have actually relocated outside of
wellsborn to be closer to family okay
well that was coming to my next question
I'll just ask what do you have any idea
what the occupancy of Eddington Lodge is
so are they roughly comparable
and in terms of the new houses of the
proposed
um what's the precise breakdown you say
the mix is one two three and four bed
what are the actual numbers of each
no she's you know has a mix and I want
to precisely how many of each Do You
Want It by tenure or just buy a bedroom
site because my bedroom is fine just
number of bedrooms so how many one
bedroom house okay thanks
hmm
okay we've got 21 number one to two beds
of those four are one beds
they help members to have a look at page
17 of the report where it's all set out
and I think they can talk them through
it but also we've got carry on turn
number three bets ten three and four
number four beds
okay
thank you
writer oh because I found it in just in
time
I didn't know there was a time limit
um with regards to the Bungalows of the
elderly
I noticed you're going to have some for
the disabled but will you also make the
Bungalows such that wheelchairs can be
pushed around within them or are they
going to be
um a bit too tight for that sort of
um we've provided floor plans on it um I
don't know whether they actually showed
a wheelchair turning Circle or not on
them
yeah
yeah I think we can clarify that it's
gone yeah
yeah we've kind of clarify that with the
officer
foreign
Parish Council makes no reference to the
flooding that's happened on site quite a
long time ago now actually but it did
require will it house to be before I was
a counselor actually but it required
will it house to be evacuated at the
time uh so the site has flooded in the
past
have you taken any additional measures
to avoid flooding is this the Willett
House will it house and yes all of that
area was flooded because in terms in
2007 the garage is obviously they're
completely passed at the moment so
they're going to be
investment has looked at flooding it's
considered surface water flooding and
it's got a drainage strategy based on
soakaways that will address those issues
there's no objection from the lead local
flood Authority thank you so I think
that's on the page 13 isn't it yeah
thank you for your
um councilor Parry is not been able to
attend I've already touched on that
earlier
um but I've been asked to read a
statement or read a few comments again
I'm just going to be so bad with me
um whilst I've not sorry whilst I have
no objection to the development of the
Woods house site itself it is the two
separate garage sites that are that I
object to as I feel this is a serious
case of over development as the proposed
units are extremely dense in design and
totally out of character with the
neighboring communities
plus there is a serious concern in
respect to flooding and consequently I
urge the committee to refuse the
application for these material planning
reasons in respect to the garage sites
there have also been extensive
objections through supplications
by many members of the public and is
extremely unfortunate that after so many
months of being thrown back at the
applicants concerns raised by WCC
highways in the flood team but I found
myself unable to attend this evening's
planning committee
could you just repeat the last sentence
I'm sure I've read it properly if I try
again now there have been extensive
objections to this application by many
members of the public and it is
extremely unfortunate that after so many
months of being thrown back at the
applicants
concerns Rise by WCC highways
and the flood team
as I find myself unable to attend this
evening's planning committee
so but yeah something sometimes you do
question yourself whether you've read it
properly but I think I just about read
that one okay
right then
um obviously you can't ask me any
questions on this because I'm reading it
as is the ward member so we'll move on
to points of clarification for the
officer
the same
microphone please
microphone please cancel saint
I think we're told by the lady from
Barton Wilmore
for the in fact the applicant is orbit
homes
yet according to the report we've been
given to read before the meeting the
applicant was a Mr Holt
can someone explain the link between the
two
Chris
uh it's the name of the individual
representing orbit homes
right there chairman would it not have
been better to have stated that on the
on on the paperwork
yeah I think that's something that's the
fair point my second question is
that on the update she we have
um a recommendation
to complete a section 106 planning
obligation
um
and uh about 12 months ago
this Council introduced that developer
contributions come by virtue of cell the
community infrastructure Levy
so can we have an explanation then
please as to why 106 agreement is
effectively proposed for this
development if it's approved
yeah thank you chair
um the the contributions relate to um
contributions towards public rights of
way maintenance and upkeep and
sustainable travel packs
um which is information given to Future
occupies as to bus services and so on in
the village
um and they really go outside of the
scope and remit of the silt tariff
therefore they're requested separately
picture would be the affordable housing
part as well and that is part of the
standards section 106.
that's the site please
we've been told on a piece of paper that
106 planning obligations is to secure
Financial contributions for the securing
affordable housing I want to ask a
question about it Mr Young starts
rambling on about footpaths if you're
pardon the pun and therefore I don't see
the connection it's one thing or the
other now can we have the the the the
straight line Supply yeah the straight
answer is there are two elements really
to the section 106 one is to ensure that
the affordable housing is secured in
perpetuity and the second element are
two requests for financial contributions
uh relating to public rights of way and
sustainable travel packs
I think we'll think we'll move along I
think we've got the answer to that one
um
any any other questions counts the
feeling just repeating my question about
sizes of the non-disabled Bungalows at
my age it's important that you make sure
you can get a wheelchair around
but sure we don't happen to have a um a
paper copy of the Bungalow layout with
us
um so it would mean having to go on to
the um onto the system to try and get
that on the overhead yeah we can find
the information for you it's going to
take us two or three minutes searching
on the computer to do that because we
don't have a paper copy of a plan do you
want to spend the time doing that no
don't worry just if we can whenever if
it goes forward that it's born in mind
in the final documentation yeah thank
you
yes one one more thing chairman about
the reference to highways uh opinion
which was alluded to in an answer Mr
Young gave a moment to go in the
objections from councilor Parry it
starts talking about the implications
for refuse collection
now as Mr Barker knows I'm aware that
that is covered by the Deep Department
of Transport manual for streets he and I
have had conversations about it quite
often he's nodding in agreement now
which I'm grateful
so are we going to be satisfied that the
challenge is that the local War member
perceives over refuse collection are
going to be practical
we're told by the lady from Barton
Wilmore that we don't have this much or
that much or anything else because we're
not changing the number of dwellings
well the the scheme was designed in the
1960s the requirements for open space
and traffic may have been less than they
would be would be for a scheme that's
designed in 2019.
therefore I want to be satisfied that
the the movement of vehicles and the
refuse collection vehicles around this
site is going to be feasible without
causing problems
the the design of the layout has been um
very very heavily involved with input
from uh the council's waste and
recycling officer and he's given
consideration to the bin carried
distances and storages in is an entirely
happy with the arrangement submitted
plans which actually aren't shown on the
overheads here show tracking
arrangements for the refuse vehicle and
they all demonstrated that the um that
the development can be readily serviced
by that vehicle we can chat
okay cancel Brian
only because it's been raised on the
portfolio order for Waste and Recycling
for the authority just to mention that
because it's been raised
thank you
I think we've exhausted the questions
yeah
go on to the Dubai and who wants to
start Council Brian
catch the barns so I'd like to start a
town I'm thoroughly disappointed that
the ward member whose excuse for not
being here is Bazaar I have to say and
the published Council there's a number
of members I think councilor Kendall is
a member of Wells warm Parish Council
and he probably could tell us why
there's non-attendance from Paris
council tonight
of his mind it and it's not too
embarrassing you're not embarrassing I
have no idea why nobody else could come
we have a standing Arrangement because I
sit on this committee I don't get asked
to come along but I don't know sorry
all the funds have been raised really
the covered in the report or the
consultives don't have any objection so
we can't question any speakers because
they're not here so I'm mindful to
recommend that we go with the officer's
recommendation on the proposer
cancel the bonds
the questions really that were in the
report from the parish and the ward
members they weren't here as far as I
were concerned she seemed to know what
she was talking about she had proper
answers and I'm quite satisfied although
I'm looking at it originally I wasn't
but I'm quite satisfied there quite
happy to Second the recommendation
which case it wants to be out you beat
me to because I was going to ask the
questions but you beat me to say thank
you for asking the the agent the
questions so we've had a proposal of
second as anybody else want to speak in
the debate
no
um obviously we've got the revised
recommendation in the update sheet so
you're happy with that one counter Brown
so um we'll go to about all those in
five of Grant in the application as per
the officer's report
against
committee approved excuse me can we see
it approves resolves even so yeah
I'm sorry
um to Grant application 18 slash zero
zero nine nine seven ful
thank you very much Anthony
chair at the point I raised about the
um rooms being white and older don't get
always in the Mongols is that going to
be taken into account
yeah all right we'll move next to the
next item on the agenda which is
19005 aut green and farm Willington
outline plan application for two
detached dwellings and garages with use
of existing access so and I'll pass on
to Anthony before I joke again thank you
chair and the application is in outline
for two dwellings in the settlement
known as Willington and you can see it
on the land Ranger map there south east
of uh chipston on stower with the black
dot
red the red Edge as you can see it's uh
to the uh east of this small settlement
in a paddock area
uh just a bit of a wider view that's
just repeating the information
and here we have an illustrative layout
as to how to housing would be
accommodated on the site
and x marks the spot here in terms of
the site on the aerial photograph
it also serves to illustrate members the
key issue in this application which is
um
where is the physical confines where
where do officers consider that to be
and having considered the the guidance
note that we've been using for many
years which is uh connecting connection
with the former local plan we continue
to use that guidance and I think this
aerial photograph clearly shows that the
site is outside of that confine there
are no there are no enclosing buildings
to Northeast or South that might might
suggest otherwise
and some shots
um with a map extract just to show you
with the blue arrow as to where they
they they were taken from
looking across the site
so it's open land
again
I this was included because the point
was made that
the argument was put that it's
potentially in a sustainable location
because of its proximity to shipston on
star and the argument was put that
people can access ships to non-stower
Across the fields but office officers
consider this as insufficient as a means
of access it's not paved it's not lit
and it really is an outline settlement
that is considered not to be sustainable
and therefore not appropriate for
further residential development in this
form
the recommendation of members is to
refuse thank you chair
sorry chair just there is uh information
on the update sheet which members may
have digested thank you
yeah we're trying to catch me out there
won't you Auntie right
um our first Speaker Pete please which
is Mrs bygate and Julia day
you could introduce yourself ladies and
let me know
um how you listen up the three minutes
or is one person speaking the other for
questions if you could just let me know
let us know please
sorry hello I'm Julia day I'm the agent
I have I like it I'm not here to speak
just in the capacity of support and to
answer questions at the end if need be
but Mrs Spygate will be using over three
minutes Britt that's great thank you
can I just say before we start that I do
wear hearing aids and they're not
compatible with your Loops so just bear
with me if I can't hear you okay just
just indicate if you can't hear us all
just live or whatever okay we'll do
thank you
by the way you've got three minutes
so my name's Sharon bargate and I'm the
applicant thank you for giving me the
opportunity to discuss my application in
more detail I started this process about
a year ago as I simply can't afford to
live in my current home which is green
and farm for much longer my husband
passed away four years ago
and I'm left with three young children
to bring up in a house that's
deteriorating and
um so on looking around at profit as if
quickly became a parent that this is
going to be tough for not only my
children moving there from their
childhood home but also for me leaving
my friends and community in Wellington
which I've lived in for 19 years so I
thought a good option would be to stay
in the village and apply for planning on
my garden land which is immediately to
the east of my existing home and
although it's called Green end farm it's
not actually been farmed on for at least
40 years so my children I love living in
a village we've got strong links here my
husband was deeply passionate about
everything that went on in the village
he was chair of the Paris Council for
about 10 years so it does matter to me
and my children what happens here my
children's school bus comes down my
driveway and my neighbors have been
really supportive since my husband died
I'd hate to lose his support
these plans are purely for illustrative
purposes and are completely flexible I'm
seeking outline Fanning here and we've
been more than happy to discuss the size
design appearance of the houses at a
later stage subject to council's
requirements I'm proposing one of the
houses is a self-build for my family and
I and if there's interest the second
house could be also be a self-build
food in one or two two houses here would
not encroach into open Countryside as
suggested
it's also been suggested the site would
be unsustainable because Williamson is
not listed as a category one to four
settlement in the core strategy but it
is within easy reach of ship Stone it's
about a mile and a half away not much
further away from the Town Center than
the houses built recently on the Camden
Road we walk or side to ships to nearly
every Sunday to visit my parents we go
across the fields and we go on the road
into ships done it's about 20 minutes
walking and obviously quicker if you're
cycling
I've lived in ships and until I was 23
and never strayed far from there my
parents live in ships and my father's
just recently diagnosed with dementia so
I go there all the time to look after
him and help them extremely challenging
and difficult situations
and staying close would enable me to
keep looking after them and provide them
with the support that we don't get from
local Services I use ships and on a
daily basis it forms part of my life a
food shop 30 seconds doctors dentists
Opticians and my children play rugby
there the proposed houses will be built
to the highest environmental standards
including electrical electric vehicle
charging points Renewable Energy
Technologies such as solar panels it's
really important to me and my children
as my husband used to run a business
that sold many of these products I know
the importance of using them and I can't
see how two houses here would just would
be against the national aims of carbon
reduction so sustainability involves
economic environmental and social
aspects as I propose because I asked you
to wrap up you know come to the end of
this sentence yeah I can ensure using
local businesses to carry out the work
thank you
I hope I didn't want to
put you off too much right any questions
cancel Fielding
um
you see you've got two children what
sort of age are they
sorry sorry three children so my
youngest is 12.
um my next one's 15 and the next one's
16. and they go to the local school in
they're at bloxom school and bloxham yes
and the other one is are you considering
these properties to be local needs
definitely yeah definitely I think
although it's not in the paperwork I
didn't know or maybe I misread it so
there would be local needs properties
yeah actually they're not I think that I
think Council building would have been
it would have mentioned in the papers
that it was that it's not it's they are
open market properties but again just to
confirm that with the officer when we
have our technical questions but I think
they are open market properties
all right Council Barnes you're
indicated well yes it was sort of we'll
come back to you on that one
say it's in an unsustainable
now you're saying is is there a river
that the map that we have on at the
moment is the river across between that
and the main road or
a foot path or so this is two football
cederships and we actually go do go
across the river and uh it takes you
into the old London Road internships and
which is the quickest route or you can
go down a footpath down another route no
River and that's 20 20 minutes yeah and
if we were to approve the houses
as you said there isn't a local lead but
they would be in your name
yes
yeah do you want to come in and clarify
that myself please oh the simple chair
that they are open market Properties or
dwellings
there's no restriction being placed on
them at all
would you like to make a comment on that
I'll on this occasion that you
thank you for my yes the the
application's been deliberately
described as at least one self-built
property that's a Sharon
um and it is clear that there is a local
need in terms of the needs the district
to provide self-built units
and there's also a national requirement
self-cooled units right thank you very
much
any further questions we'll clarify that
a bit we'll cover all that yeah I did
say We'll crack a lot with the officer
as well the proper definitions Etc is
just so we're under No Illusion of what
we're we're talking about on this
application uh you're free to go now
ladies thank you very much
and
can we have our award member please
councilor O'Donnell
thanks
obviously you've got five minutes
whenever you're ready canceling on
a good evening committee there are three
key areas which drove me to bring this
before you the long-term impact of
non-sustainability judgments upon other
rural settlements such as Wellington the
interpretation of the nppf and our own
core strategy particularly cs-15 cs-16
and as10 I believe these policies allow
Southfield in rural areas which has
proposed here
and finally our approach to South build
targets at Stratford District Council
the buy gates are woven into the very
fabric of Wellington Mrs bygate is not a
speculative landowner looking to make a
quick buck
the plot is currently part of the
baygate's garden of note immediately to
the north is a recent six House
Development knows more sustainable than
this application in terms of distance
from shipston
the argument on unsustainability was
made throughout the office's report but
that seems to only consider the location
of this site ignoring other aspects of
sustainable development such as social
and economic matters
as a forward-looking committee I would
ask you to view sustainability with an
eye to the Future the CLA recently found
that many villages across the UK are
overlooked by local planning process as
they are judged unsustainable due to
lack of public services
as a result unsustainable Villages are
not allocated housing and have severely
limited development options to improve
their sustainability
surely this is outdated it is vital that
we consider this social capital the
network of relationships among people
who work and live in a particular
society enabling that Society to
function effectively
send sustainable development is about
action not just maintaining the status
quo we should be asking what do we want
our communities to look like in 20 years
time and how do we achieve that
nppf paragraph 78 supports rural
development and says where there are
groups of smaller settlements
development in warm Village May Support
Services in a village nearby and Mrs
bygate has Illustrated how they utilize
many of shipston's facilities regularly
the site is within Willington and in all
other settlements category cs-15 this
does not make it unsuitable for
development while such a category is at
the bottom of the hierarchy of
Development Area types it is advised in
cs-16 at 750 homes will be built in such
other rural settlements across the
district this application would reduce
that Target as10 wording supports
Community small scale schemes for
housing employment or Community
facilities to meet a need identified by
a local community in a parish plan
neighborhood plan or other form of local
evidence on land within or adjacent to a
village as far as I can see this is a
small-scale housing scheme which will
benefit the community by providing
self-built housing and allow this family
to stay within the village there are no
technical objections from highways
ecology or Environmental Health in
addition I refer you to the planning
appeals finding we adminton which I
understand has already been forwarded to
you just out of Willington Edmonton is a
other rural settlement site the
inspector also noted CS 16 750 homes
Target in such settlements he made
observations in respect of the appeal
site not having convenient access to
services and Facilities other than by a
private car observing this is not a
requirement under cs-15 and as-10 the
inspector noted that the benefit of
housing in such areas including the
proposed development is the contribution
they can make to the Vitality of these
rural communities indeed our own cs-15
we note the principle of sustainability
relates to a wide range of factors
environmental economic and social and
not just the limited issues such as the
need to travel to the council it is
important to ensure that communities of
all types can be sustained into the
future preferably as a result of gradual
and organic growth moving on to
self-build I was interested to learn
that there are currently 111 people on
the self-built register 18 of these are
looking for um the ship scenario
specifically and 13 are not
site-specific therefore potentially 40
people could be looking at this
self-built opportunity and reduce the
number on that register in a sustainable
location and not encroaching on open
Countryside our core strategy
explanation for cs-16 Housing
Development says there are a number of
mechanisms that can contribute to
meeting the housing needs of the
district and the council supports the
privilege settings have been delivered a
self-built projects finally the
government indicates that it believes
self will can play an important role in
delivering high quality housing that
meets the needs of all sectors of the
community councils have a legal duty to
give suitable development permission to
enough suitable service plots of land to
meet the demand for self-built and
custom house building in their area
granting planning permission would
certainly help with this Duty I believe
this to be a unique case and I look
forward to hearing your thoughts
thank you spot on and write questions
for the order number against the brain
firstly chairman I have to declare that
I'm the ward member for Edmonton I was
involved with that planning application
but I'm here with a hope and mind on
this agenda item okay
um probably cancer won't be able to
answer my question I apologize I should
have asked Mrs bygate the question I
presume the South builders for herself I
think we heard that it was does that
mean that the house she's living in will
be open market once she moves into the
South build
I presume it would be but I would need
to double check that for you
because the reason they're looking to
move is because they financially cannot
maintain the house they're in
so that's why
I think um
the applicant in the agent did not uh
their confirmation it would be open
market if they were to vacate it
right uh anybody else because I've got a
question if nobody else has one
um
very briefly
um yeah it's to do a local
um
we've
we've had used sport in it obviously
there's been no comment from the parish
council
there's been one item and one letter of
support in the report one of no
objection and four objections to the
application
um usually when there's a strong local
need there seems to be more support and
more letters of support the parish
council rights and all actually attends
I just wondered why this is not the case
in this application it's my
understanding it's a parish meeting and
they held a specific Parish meeting
about the application and Mrs mygate
answered any concerns they had and
engaged fully with them and spoke with
them and nobody really had any major
objections
so it was felt that I think they felt as
they weren't objecting that was all they
had to do I don't believe they're an
overly active Parish meeting to be
honest maybe twice a year yeah I'm
excited if
sometimes it probably would have been
better if if they did support it to
sending a letter of support or actually
tend or get somebody to attend the
meeting that would have set down so
stronger signal to the comedian they
might have been cancer side I can see
your mission to come in on this one I
might be speaking out a turn chairman
don't worry I'm used to that so but uh
effectively barchester and Willington
doesn't have a parish council it's one
of those very small villages that has a
parish meeting
and I was their County councilor for 16
years so I'm very familiar with how that
Parish works and indeed when it was
under Mrs by Gay's husbands
care and uh and everything else that he
put into it when he was a very active
person there
um so but but basically they don't meet
that regularly they have to convene
special meetings as plenty owners
suggested to look up planning issues
um and then therefore I think we can
take that point that the war member
mentions as being quite uh that had been
quite realistic yeah I'm saying it might
be a good idea when the ward member goes
back if she does speak to them that not
at tacit approval it has less weight
than a written support of the
application
um I know that they don't be very ready
but they did say they had a special
meeting for this so again was there any
admits of that meeting
Etc and it would have been ideal if we'd
had some formal a formal notification of
a report in my opinion
well they have a long-standing uh Parish
secretary who I thought would have been
on top of that
against the balance sorry cancer Brian
then yeah just on that matter
just on that matter it's misleading the
page 27 it says barchester and
Willington Parish Council I find that
misleading what am I going to that as
well
any further questions for the award
number
I can't say I don't know you're free to
go thank you
and we'll now move on to Christians for
the officer
Council Barnes
I think we do clarification on need for
open market or whatever if the self
Builder usually for people specific
people aren't they
might still come in first when you're
coming onto me to try and clarify it so
basically they would start as an open
market dwelling liable to the full the
Civil charge
then they have to go through a full step
criteria to apply for a self-built
exemption now to go through the south
building
um the criteria that goes through that
like that four steps
then the council could consider that is
this is a self-build property
now one of those criteria is actually
living in the properties as your
principal residence for three years
now if they manage to do that fine and
with all the other criteria they
wouldn't pay any still charge but when
they come to sell that property after
three years it would still be an open
market property
did you indicate no not an escaping
cancer Fielding
on to that point
um you can't then turn it into a local
needs situation
but they haven't asked for local needs
but they haven't asked for a local needs
property
they've asked for self-build and one
open-market dwelling
yeah we just have a slight adjournment
a bit clarified something yeah we are
current on something
um
obviously we've talked about
Southfield and local needs
um
and as far as I can tell and discussions
with
archives on the top here
neither of those categories have been
applied for in this application
so
um together so we're just getting
clarification from one to me on this
if you could come by
probably Tech Team probably yeah yeah
you
um
so two questions self-build or local
needs
um
clearly the developers coming forward
with the self-built scheme
um that isn't isn't a local needs scheme
um
now
the question I think needs to be teased
apart we need to consider it as a
proposed which is a self-built scheme
it's not complying with the local needs
side of our core strategy policy
[Music]
um
members may be aware of the emerging
site allocations plan which talks about
self-build gives officers and the
council more guidance on where this may
occur
and policy sap one says that it may
occur within an adjacent to Stafford
upon Avon the main rural centers on
local service villages
so it doesn't fall within the scope of
this emerging policy this is the only
guidance we have at the moment
but it strikes and is being good
guidance
where where schemes fall outside of that
guidance we have to take it that it's
like any other open market housing
within the countryside where there's
presumption against development
um
I'd like to remind members of
the local need scheme policy and that
clearly says that within an adjacent to
settlements development may include
small-scale community-led schemes and
then we turn to our development
management guidance document and it says
that evidence of identification of need
should come have come from a recent
Parish housing needs survey or surveys
and or technical work prepared as part
of any Parish plan stroke neighborhood
plan
so it seems very clear to officers that
this is an open market scheme
um which doesn't comply with policy and
there are no material or compelling
material reasons to override the the
substantial and driving primary
um consideration of the core strategy
the position of officers is that the
correct decision on this application is
refusal this application is not a a
self-built application this application
is not a local needs application
the correct decision is therefore
refusal if the applicant wants to come
forward and make those cases then they
should come forward with an application
that does that it should be evaluated as
such and we should come to you with a
fully understood scheme rather than
teasing information out as we sit here
tonight as we sit here tonight this
application is is very clearly contrary
to your policies and contrary to your
practice on on dwellings on the
periphery of of small villages
and that's why officers have come
forward to you with a recommendation for
refusal
right thank you for that I think that
was
pretty clear that counts are failing but
wouldn't it be possible to defer it for
the
uh
it's applicant to come forward with a
revised thing or if he wants to you can
make the proposal cancer filled in what
you'll need support and from the rest of
the committee to or the majority of the
committee to do that so it's reasons to
depose you um you know the planning
reasons for the deferral
ingredients I would have thought is the
very argument that's just been put
forward between local needs and
self-build
um it would it not be possible for that
to be sorted out by the applicant
so Ryan
we have to deal with this application on
its minutes what's in front of us
tonight if they want to come back with
an application it'll have to be a new
application so I don't think the
deferral will get support
it's not I think
just like
a little candle which okay I think I
agree with Council brand I think he said
I was thinking as well I think to ask
for a deferral would muddy the waters we
should deal with this application before
us and whatever the applicants want to
do it's up to them are we still in
points of clarification or debate
he moved from one to the other I think
catch the percent
oh we're on to the debate yet
um we all know we've had a proposal to
defer have we got a second for cancer
fielding's proposed I'm going back if
you want to put it this way
I don't think that's going to make it
any further forward
because they they have learned a lot
sitting here so can I take it catch the
barn so you don't you're not willing to
support cancer fielding's proposal I'll
take our second development
you also
that there appears to be less
professional advice that they've been
given and the possibility that we they
may be able to move forward if we defer
it
that's it that's what that's not a
reason I I don't really know I'm trying
to get to the bottom of it's
particularly happy with that but I think
we've we've got to propose in a second
to move this on we'll go to the right
whether to defer this application or not
so all those in favor of agreeing to
defer this application please indicate
to each other and those against
so that proposal Falls so we'll now go
back to the debate
to
well we morphed in from technical
questions into the debate so we will now
officially start the debate you know
as Churchill would say
like cancer site you couldn't start now
please
Mr chairman
um I'd like to take issue with some of
the comments that have been made this
evening in relation to planning policy
I'm not normally one that wants to go
against policy in fact I had a fair
amount of a big hand in contributing
towards the policy that does exist as
everybody in the room knows
but I effectively am happy to support
this application on the grounds that the
council policy is adequate
uh let's forget about all these
technicalities over self-build and
Market housing and what have you we're
talking about a parish which probably
has what 60 or 70 houses in it we're
proposing to put two more in it
and that will enable Mrs by gates to
keep up her residence within the village
itself
to move into a new house instead of
having to redevelop an existing one so
presumably whoever buys it will do that
but that's a speculative point which is
irrelevant
I was a bit surprised where Mr Young
started going on about built up area
boundaries
build our area boundaries have been
devised for local service Villages and
it's been well established that
barchiston and Willington is not a local
service Village at all
it comes under the category of other
settlements
of which councilor O'Donnell has
correctly pointed out there is a
planning policy requirement for 750
houses in such settlements across the
entire District
and I would have thought the two here
would have matched that perhaps they
might even need four or five in
barchiston to actually match their fair
share of that allocation so that's one
policy position that really does support
this application
the fact that we need a certain amount
you can't let Villages stagnate you have
to have an opportunity
and I'm well aware I'm I'm prepared to
take on trust we never know what's going
to happen in the future
the defectively if these houses are
granted and built that Mrs bygate will
move into one of them and she will
remain part of the village I think I
know the people there well enough to
accept that that is a a simple fact of
life
let's have a look at the position this
particular site is not a particularly uh
attractive site
it's bounded by the main road in a field
and therefore you can't argue that
there's anything on the outside that
might give it some likelihood of
matching up so the vernacular style of
the village is well away from here as
you can see from there and you've got
odds of buildings of all their own
individual character dotted about all
over the place
between the road that goes around their
site and the river that Mrs baygate
refers to that they can walk down to and
cross presumably there's a bridge down
there somewhere
um you know and they can get across to
walk into shipston
um it's very very very close indeed
so much so that the ships and
neighborhood plan
got held up with a big argument about a
bit of land that was on their side of
the river but was actually in Batista
and Wellington Parish
and there was a hell of a kerfuffle and
a hell of a difficulty oversorting that
one out but that's been resolved and I
think this can be resolved by us saying
that there is a policy requirement for a
certain proportion of these houses so we
can't just turn around and say no
policy says you don't build in a village
like this
policy doesn't say that at all in my
view
I'm Motley people that want to disagree
with me but that is my view
and the entrance to this particular site
is uh is is through an area that's not
very attractive and I think the house is
effectively will improve the general
layout and appearance of that end of the
village so I would like to propose that
we Grant this application I expect the
officers will want to sort out
conditions with us to support me but I'm
happy in the usual way for them to take
a lead on this
it's failing
um can you put your microphone on please
um cs50
has gone together around number 15.
um local needs schemes
um are encouraged within the villages
and CS
10 catch the field and we've already
we've already established it's been not
identified as a local need scheme no but
I'm just trying to just to clarify them
getting in support of what council
Saints said yeah
um as10 it's small scale within the
community
and also the fact that
um other terms within CS tend to give
um under b10b residential or otherwise
within the physical confines in
accordance with 15. and in my book as a
um the the road that does
enclose the area both on three sides and
I can't see why this development should
not go forward and I'm prepared to
Second counselor Saints if that if this
is a
a proposal
I must admit I
I'm concerned that we're still confused
about this there are too many
uncertainties on my on this you know is
it local need is it Southfield is it
Market open market
and as councilor Williams used to be on
this committee he used to say if
something's not quite right if it's
wrong and I think this this is not quite
right
and we talk about all of the settlements
and if you look in the policy it says
development is restricted to small-scale
community-led schemes which meet a
scheme identified by the local community
and in my opinion I don't think it does
but it's up to the committee to decide
on this one we've had a proposer and a
second to Grant this application
councilor Brian before
the German I think we all have some
sympathy towards this application but
the application we got before it is the
wrong application it is clearly against
policy I'm not going to go into the
argument with cancer is saying but their
core strategy is clear it's against
polity it's the wrong application we've
got before us and I think it should be
refused and ask the applicant to come
back with another application
okay we'll we'll go on we need some
conditions at the airport to Grant yeah
actually
we've had a proposing a second uh to go
against the officer's recommendation and
chair can we just clarify the reasons to
actually uh go against the officers
recommendations as well please
um and I've been asked to clarify the
reasons of going against the planning
officers application um recommend
donation
15 refers to small-scale development
okay
it is not as such a community in the
form that there is a parish council
there but uh so Council can you can you
help me which part of cs15 are you
thinking of
um I can can indeed
sir oh gee sorry
within the adjacent to settlement
development that may include small case
community-led schemes I know it's not
community-led but it is somebody who
lives in the community who's leading it
um
but
Jim can we can we take it as read that
this is an outline application so
there'll be the the standard Reserve
matters condition the standard time
scales
um is there anything else that members
would want well we've got a list of
suggested conditions
so this is a three-year time limit
condition approved plans uh maximum of
two dwellings details layout scale
appearance access and Landscaping to be
submitted and approved a construction
management plan foul and surface water
disposal access parking and maneuvering
areas to be completed prior to First
occupation
land contamination assessment and
Remediation where necessary
remediation to be completed as approved
wheelie bins
and cabling for EV charging points
gentlemen are you happy to accept those
conditions I'm I'm happy to accept those
Sherman yeah so we've got a proposal and
secondary to Grant the application
in with the conditions proposed by Mr
Young there so all those in favor
follows against
three chairman
and my custom vote goes with the against
the recommendation against proposals to
refuse sorry against the proposal to
Grant
and we now need to go back to
the refusal the refusal so I need uh
anybody
out of the three of us
okay I will write the proposal that we
go with the office of recommendation to
refuse the application seconded by
cancer the bonds a brain brain sorry
cancer brain
anyway so all those in favor
against
two chairman and abstentions one
chairman committee resolves to refuse
application
19005 and UT
we're going to have a two-minute
adjournment uh due to some issues it's
just a reason so and if you want to go
Council Brian thank you
right sorry for that ladies and
gentlemen and thank you for bearing with
us um a slight issue
uh happened on this application which is
18-03215 slash very
uh before we go
to this application
um
the district council went through its
normal processes and we've we've met our
obligations
um
but the applicant uh
wanted to speak a wide representations
about this
application
um and we actually felt we went through
the right processes to go ahead with
this application
and if we did the applicant wouldn't be
able to speak on this matter
because there was some confusion
and
we feel the only way the applicant can
speak on this application is to defer
the item to the next agenda
um and that's what I'm asking for the
committee to agree to
on the next item then we're seeking
approval from the committee to defer
this item so the applicant then make is
representations
if we didn't do any other way the
applicant would not be able to speak on
this application
if it's your judgment chairman that's
the appropriate thing to do I'm happy to
support you
yeah yeah so if required proposal
because of our second year podcast all
those in favor for deferral
five chairman
against
there's abstentions not we all agreed on
that one I wouldn't have sent you yes
we have this is as much of Public
Records who sit on the microphone
um
but uh
going forward
down can correct me if I'm wrong but I
do believe there was some paperwork
about the applicant speaking at at some
time in the past or his firm being
notified that the matter would come
before committee unfortunately the
speaker really basically should have
made sure that the actual matter was
that committee on this certain date and
registered but he did Express an
interest at some time previously to
actually be notified it's not the
district council's job to actually
notify an objector or a speaker
and therefore because of the confusion
that they requested to speak they didn't
exactly well they didn't register
appropriately appropriately like they
should have done then we've actually
assessed that the best matter of way of
resolving this is for it to be deferred
so both sides can actually speak next
time in three weeks
to fairness
I wonder about that
for other reasons as well at night um
gets deferred halfway through the so
yeah so we can only apologize and thank
you for being with us and we note
we know your objection there as well yes
thank you
right so committee resolves to defer
application
18-03215
thank you
right we'll now move on to our
applications
number item seven on the agenda which is
18 slash
zero three one three six fuel
ington house one Farm close harboring
fun application for a new dwelling and
access
and our presented officer is Alice and
worse regardless of
thank you Mr chairman
the application site is situated in
harbury as shown by the black dot
the application involves the development
of a character two-bed house on a plot
of land on Farm Street in the
conservation area there are two listed
buildings slightly further along Farm
Street Number 27 and stone walls on the
opposite side of the road
here's an aerial view showing the
location of the application site in
harbory noted by the red marker
the application site fronts onto Farm
Street
the private Access Road
the private access to Farm close is on
the north side of the plot
this is a development of four detached
houses built approximately 20 years ago
this Allington house which is separated
from the application site by an existing
double garage and outbuilding there is
another Cottage built to the south of
the site number 36 35 Farm Street
partially screen from the streets by
trees and the low brick wall
the site is currently Surplus Garden
area the Arlington House retaining
separate Garden to the South shown by
the blue line
this slide shows plans and elevations
for the new house designed to complement
the local vernacular
two bedrooms modest sized footprint 56
square meters 6.6 meters to the ridge
the main part of the building is built
with a red brick single story section
and porch made of Natural Stone
the roof would be finished with
reclaimed plane clay tiles
this slide shows the proposed layout of
the site with a garden to the rear set
back from the pavement with a small
front garden which will be planted with
shrubs
it's set further back from the pavement
than their next door house an older
house as per the village design
statement requirements
that's
here
there are two parking spaces for the two
bed Cottage accessed off Farm close
some of the sycamores
boundary wool and the grass area is to
be retained to soften the view to the
North in this area
Arlington House is on the right hand
side of the screen here
it's separated by a double garage
and an outbuilding here
there's adequate off-road parking
retained for Allington house
that's here
there are currently Seven Trees along
the west boundary of the site six
Sycamore and one Rowan the Opera culture
report assesses them as Class C only the
report the the proposed design requires
the removal of four of the trees whilst
the the mate the remaining
um
whilst three of them will will remain in
this area
here
foreign
this slide shows the application site
with Farm Road to the left of the
picture Behind These trees
this slide shows the trees along the
front of the plot this is taken from
Farm Road sorry Farm Street the group
further away would be retained so these
would be retained these will be removed
so they're self-some Sycamore
this slide shows Arlington House and the
existing double garage and double
parking space that would be retained
this slide shows the rear Garden of
Allington house which would be retained
this slide shows the view looking North
along Farm Street
the application site is behind the trees
Mr chairman that's the end of my
presentation there are three updates Mr
chairman as detailed on the update sheet
and the recommendation is to approve the
application for the reasons detailed in
the report subject to the updates thank
you thank you arson can we have our
first Speaker which is cancer Tim
lockley from
probably post cancer
good evening Miss Oakley thank you for
bearing with us tonight uh you've got
three minutes
because that speeded things up quite
considerably
um can I have my slides that we're
working on please
were you want a warning within 30
seconds of your time why not hopefully I
won't need it
there you go okay thank you the first
thing to talk about is the numbers game
it's interesting that you put so much
emphasis on policy in one of the
previous applications Stratford has a
clear policy in its course strategy
about local service Villages like
harbury uh we're supposed to take about
450 houses over the course strategy
period while officers have been granted
in total more than 800 houses in the
local service category one Villages like
harbury already and the original 12
years of the core strategy left so uh
um these things aren't necessarily being
observed all the time and I think that's
a real worry but this is maybe a
conversation for another time
the second thing to say is that I really
don't think the people in harbury want
this development and why do I say that
is well we just went through an
extensive neighborhood development plan
process took four years extensive
consultation with the people they
designed the policies and policy number
one
stresses a number of things which this
if this application is granted it would
violate including the policy about
developing Garden land the impact on the
conservation area as you can see in
Pinky's Harbor's Conservation Area and
this lies a light slap bang in the
middle of it and I don't see any way in
which this would enhance our
Conservation Area in fact it will damage
it because there's no way that this
house could blend into the existing
Conservation Area because a lot of those
current houses are built with
Harborstone and you can't get
hubblestone anymore the Quarry is closed
and it's been closed for decades
I don't see it being able to match in
and it contravenes harboring able to
development plan H1 and then could you
put the next slide up please
and then I think we should maybe play
you know what Spot the Difference
um this is a uh a slide showing the two
applications for this house one of them
is the house that is the application
we're currently considering the other
one is uh one that was refused by
Stratford offices uh two years ago I
think you'd be hard pushed to tell the
difference
um and in fact the planning officer who
considered it two years ago found that
it contravened numerous of Stratford's
own policies including as10 cs15 cs-16
um by the way as10 and cs15 are about
the site is not suitable and I don't see
how any kind of change has happened uh
with that and it constantly contravenes
uh policies section cs8 cs9 I see it's
15 about the status of the conservation
area and it will do a Justified harm to
the setting of listed buildings this
entire site was of course within the
historic cartilage of a listed building
which is uh just next door
um it would also have a damaging effect
on residential amenities so those are
the the documents that the harbury
parish council would put forward thank
you
brilliant so
well in time so have we any questions
for councilor lockley
cancel that
feeding um there was a two-bedroom
Cottage refused two years ago it is on
the same plot yeah so the one that that
slide you're looking at the one on the
left was refused two years ago the one
on the right is the one you're
considering tonight all right oh thank
you that's why I put them to the two
together so you could see that there was
uh well almost no difference between
these two okay
possibility
the one on the right on the left sorry
that doesn't appear to have or the the
trees and the um
Landscaping that the one on the right
does is that correct
well I can see a great big tree on both
applications
um
we point the clarification
let's look at um Argos small question
um
hobby quite well I've played football
against celebrity they're right
um but one of the two Hustlers drinking
lemonade of course yeah
um can you just remind me
of some of the houses nearby like the
age the the stone the brick Etc and the
ones nearby just yeah so so the listic
building which is immediately to the
north which is number 27 is built of
Harvey Stone the one opposite stonewalls
is also bill of Harvey Stone
um Harbor Stone came from the hobby
Quarry which is now uh fishing lakes
because the Quarry has been quarried out
and there's no no means of getting that
stone the house to the South which I
think is there's a picture of is uh
vernacular brick with Harborstone at the
bottom and it's a particular type of
limestone that looks different from any
other Limestone and numerous planning
applications in recent years have tried
to match harbury Stone and they all fail
uh quite spectacularly and they always
look jarringly different from
Harborstone
um
very much I think even
you've told the story about that so
thank you thank you any further
questions
thank you very much so you're ready to
go
and have we got Adrian Lewis here please
thank you very much
slides move on yeah once already you'll
have three minutes from there and again
we'll give you a shout with 30 seconds
to go how do I change it how do I get
the slides to change just just nod them
yeah and we'll give you a little bit
extra time
okay
right have yourself okay so I'm Adrian
Lewis I'm representing the 22 objectives
to this planet application many of whom
are here tonight next slide
in 1996 this planet Authority granted
permission for the concept of
construction of four large dwellings on
land off Farm Street this subsequently
became Farm close
protect the conservation area permission
was granted with conditions condition
eight of which ensured appropriate
Landscaping of the Open Spaces and the
maintenance of these it was a
controversial application with over 40
objectives but an acceptable layout was
agreed and key to this was the setting
of the houses far back from Farm Street
with the inclusion of a substantial
landscape screen next slide
successful planning applications for
tree works on the landscape screen to
let more light into the garden and
office the latter reason is quite ironic
because if the development proceeds the
office windows will be filled in in
order to comply with planning
regulations
given the Landscaping obligations placed
by the planning Authority I am uncertain
why permission for these tree Works was
granted
however the planning officer is
suggesting that because of these works
the screen is now less effective next
slide
these two photographs were taken this
week and I believe show that despite the
inappropriate tree works the screen
remains effective it is worth bearing in
mind that it's still winter informally
if it is even more effective next slide
the planning officer is also suggesting
that the construction of the proposed
dwelling may be a more effective screen
than this I don't see this and wonder
how anyone can justify a screen at a
house with a house next slide
these are the front cover of the design
and access statements submitted by the
applicant's developer note a previous
application 2016 was refused I lead you
to consider if such a dwelling provides
more effective and appropriate screening
in the conservation area than this next
slide
it is worth being aware that Farm close
is a shared access private road with
maintenance responsibility split equally
between the four properties as such it
is unclear if the restrictive covenants
allow for any one party to make
unilateral changes to the road access if
this precluded access for this
development would need to come off Farm
Street in summary we believe that the
proposed dwelling would adversely impact
the conservation area and the settings
of the two listed buildings this is why
this land was effectively sterilized
from development by the planning
Authority in 1996 and used to form an
effective landscape screen from the Farm
close development and why in 2017 your
planning officer refused a similar
application I'd also like to point out
that the outbuilding referenced in the
previous cloning officer slide is
actually a habitable space you can check
with the plan and application it was
approved for residential use thank you
questions for Mr Lewis
no arms the only thing is
um obviously the the sycamores are in
full with the one that's up there the
sycamores are in full
Four Leaf whatever the terminology I'm
not a trainer
um
we looked at the I think in the report
it says the trees are grade c
um as in terms of
uh type of specimen and well yeah but my
view is is those
the conditions that were put in place to
allow the Farm close development those
trees they needed to be to be maintained
so why they've been allowed to be
overgrown with I've eaten so you know I
would say what you should be
recommending is that a landscape is uh
landscape screen it's preserved action
is taken to clean them up and let the
cranes develop as they should be
and I think the point about access I
think that's a civil matter I don't
think it's in our remix
No I'm just making sure there's no the
other residents are seeking legal
guidance as to whether it's allowed or
not yeah any more questions Mr Lewis
okay thank you
and our next speaker please is Mrs
Jacqueline Johnson
you've got six six minutes Mr Johnson
yeah
yeah um and we'll give again we'll give
you a warning with 30 seconds to go okay
thank you
um
yeah hello thank you for allowing me to
speak this evening
um I'm Jacqueline Johnson and I am the
applicant so why do I want to build this
Cottage
I recently lost my husband and at the
same time my daughter left for
University
I find myself rattling around a large
five-bedroomed house which should have a
family living in it and not just me
when I looked around harbury for
suitable small detached dwellings in the
heart of the village I quickly realized
that there aren't on this highlighted a
real need for small two bed properties
for downsizers to move into whilst
remaining in the heart of the village
and freeing up larger homes for families
seem wrong for me to have this redundant
unused land just sitting there doing
nothing when it has the potential to
benefit the community
the land was actually conveyed To Us by
the Builder it stands separately from
and is not the garden to Arlington House
which has its own large Back Garden it's
a substantial front garden a double
garage plus additional parking for up to
three cars there's also ample room for
overflow parking on Fast Farm close
itself while still allowing for vehicle
access
therefore this build will take
absolutely nothing away from the
existing houses on Farm close
or Farm Street
since the previous application the plans
have been modified to accommodate
neighbors concerns and adhere to the
neighborhood development plan
furthermore the proposed Cottage will
enhance the conservation area for
example
sensitive design and scale of the
proposed Cottage will reinforce a street
scene and complement the two listed
buildings by adopting some shared
features
in fact stone walls is flanked on both
sides by 70s buildings and is actually
located directly opposite number 27 and
not the proposed Cottage
the design and materials such as local
Stone secondhand brick and reclaimed
clay tiles are sympathetic to its
surroundings and typical of the historic
buildings in harbory
it will be set back not just from the
road but also the pavement the trees and
the build line
in a similar relationship to the
Cottages further down Farm Street
the most prominent trees forming Street
Scene will remain
they will become healthier due to less
crowding and continue to provide
wildlife habitat additional Landscaping
will be introduced to the northern
boundary
the beach hedge and ivy-clad wall will
be preserved it will help reduce
pollution as low Hedges have been
identified as environmentally beneficial
in supporting the production of cleaner
air
the ivy-clad wall was requested to be
put there initially hence the IV and the
trees
furthermore the proposed dwelling will
not Overlook any Back Garden
it will have its own secluded 52 square
meter rear Garden
it's worth noting that while some
residents on Farm Street have objected
at least 70 percent have not and
interestingly The Cottages immediate
neighbors both North and South have no
objection to the build
in addition
this Cottage adheres to National
planning policy development and design
principles by promoting good design
which is in keeping with the character
of the area
government guidelines and the national
planning policy framework stress is the
importance of having a planning system
that is genuinely plan LED it asserts
where a proposal Accords with a
development plan it should be approved
without delay
this proposal meets all the planning
criteria including the emerging
harboring neighborhood plan has clearly
outlined in Alison Villa's report
this is an opportunity for this
committee to have the legacy of
approving a build of a much needed
environmentally Sound small cottage
which will utilize a redundant
sustainable location
nestled behind the trees and sympathetic
towards its surroundings it will enhance
the conservation area provide a home for
downsizes and future generations and
become part of Harvey's heritage
supported by all of the expert
consulters this Cottage reflects the
blue blueprint of the harbor we see
today which grew organically in this way
I therefore respectively ask you to
approve my application
thank you for listening
thank you very much Mr Johnson any
questions please
no
no you obviously answered everybody's
question in your
speech okay right you're free to go
thank you
we move on to points of clarification
technical questions for the officer
councilor Harris I'm not used to having
award members here I am I've got you
down your number four speaker you're
here
perhaps it was talking to councilor
lockley about the hostelers in harbury
put me off and I lost the show so blind
Council luckily sorry about that sorry
I'm using your time how long have I
gotcha you've got five minutes oh that's
not long enough
thank you for listening to me and
committee members
I support obviously a lot of the things
that have said today and whilst I'm
sympathetic to the applicant because it
is a balancing acting harbury of
um
finding smaller properties and the
capacity for downsizing and it is
difficult when we go through planning to
um
make decisions but that said
I have to say I am against this for the
simple reasons I've already been stated
in the policies I'd like to remind you
that this is a garden development sits
within Harvey Conservation Area and that
hobby is an SL
lsb1 Village which is already delivered
136 new dwellings and surpassed its core
strategy allocation at most 113
we have clear capacity at over six years
or if I'm wrong in my figures is the
chair of the parish it says 12 years of
our five-year housing land Supply
I would ask you to consider the basic
tenets of the mppf
um
in regarding this application
there's none that I've seen that do
support it there's no social economic or
environmental benefit from this
application there's no material
employment no environmental benefit but
a loss of Green Space within the
conservation area we just have one more
house squeezed in adjacent to the road
and very immediate neighbor
it does concern me how close this build
would be to the adjacent house
I'd ask you also to consider the core
strategy which has already been
mentioned the key policies that I've
considered and I'm asking you to look at
would be CSA it's historic environment
cs15 distribution of development cr16
housing development at as10 the most
significant Countryside in villages and
we've already touched on these and we're
discussing others tonight
I'd say that this application sadly is
on in conflict with each of them CSA the
application is in the Harvey
Conservation Area we do not even have
the benefit of any comment from the
conservation officer I have contacted
him and he has written to me today to
say he was too busy and whilst I respect
the planning managers experiences which
matters we have no specific comment on
the Conservation Area
why do we have conservation areas in
villages such as hard we've ignore them
when the application application comes
in conservation areas are there for a
purpose and that purpose is not to be
and should not be ignored
CS 1516 Harvey is an lsv1 village with
an allocation of not more than 25 to 450
dwellings for an lsv one settlement
being 113 new dwellings yet Harvey has
already delivered 136 new dwellings in
addition to the lsv1 Villages have
delivered in total 853 dwellings out of
a total of 450. where is the shortfall
in the delivery of housing numbers
in Harbor or in lsv1 villages that
should be looking to the other types of
villages if development is needed in
rural Villages let us look at those
others such as level two three and four
local Services Villages which have yet
to meet their own sorry those local
service Villages which you have yet to
meet their own allocation
[Music]
um
why should the lsv wand continue to Bear
the brunt of unwanted or needed
development this application cannot be
considered to be supported by these two
policies in this Village and if not why
are we bothering to have these policies
as-10 rural villagers can accept further
homes in order to maintain a Vitality of
rural communities Harvey needs no such
support further this application will
have a material and adverse impact on
other occupiers and users of existing
properties in the area Conkey to as10 it
will have an impact on the conservation
area
contrary to as10 the site while small
scale is contrary to the recent adopted
neighborhood plan is not identified it's
not an identified site within that plan
and therefore again contrary to as10
where is the local support that is site
from the community I haven't really seen
any and there's none from the parish
council
in conclusion the mppf our own core
strategy the recently adopted Harvey
neighborhood plan do not support this
application I don't even know why it's
here today and why we're considering it
because we're just against all policies
just before I finish I'd like to draw
the attention there is a difference of
opinion on the neighborhood plan and it
does concern me that Harvey's been put
in a difficult position and maybe
um
and why I say that is I understand after
speaking to the portfolio holder today
after concerns around the conservation
officer not responding that is there a
disconnect between the legal and policy
aspect of neighborhood planning that
strap District councils got to revisit
guidance and advice it gives
neighborhoods parishes to Neighborhood
plans and I think I don't want to see
Harvey disadvantaged because Stratford
District Council have got it wrong thank
you
right any questions for the Lord
remember
Joe I was trying to ask his own if you
keep saying in the Conservation Area
it is in the conservation area or
looking at the map that we had before
looked as though it was in between two
or
she's in the conservations please
and the lady did say that the neighbors
were not opposing it
you might come please your microphone
please so can he your microphone
okay
so we can have your responses oh sorry
just like cancer advisors anyway I think
we've clarified that point eventually
um
thanks for your point now because I if
anybody else hasn't got a point I've got
a couple of questions
um
one's been touched on but the first
point you would almost finish saying
before I interrupted you and it wasn't
quite clear because you were rushing as
well so again I think I'll give you the
opportunity to make that point is
you're questioning
the neighborhood planning process
and the disconnect and the conservation
officer I didn't quite understand what
you're saying next so just clarify that
I'm not because
approach the conservation officer to get
a view on the conservation aspect of it
for one it led to further discussions
and he did get back to me and I won't
repeat it well I will repeat it again he
told me he was too busy to respond which
I find is inappropriate I know that um
the current planning Offices here today
have experience of conservation that
said it's led to further conversations
and have also encouraged the parish to
sit down with the planners to discuss
about the neighborhood plan on the
difference of opinion of how that is and
I understand that Darren has had a word
with the planner to acknowledge tonight
there is a difference of opinion on
about the neighborhood plan and that led
to further conversations that Darren is
going to look at being doing a piece of
work because there's a difference on
what advices come from legal what has
come and policy and we may be advising
parishes wrongly and I don't want to see
hardly disadvantaged if we've got it
wrong at Stratford on how they construct
their neighborhood plan I accept your
point that we don't want to see any
parishes disadvantage you've gone
through the neighborhood planning
process so we'll take that point on
board and we'll we'll see how we can
resolve that and make sure the
information is is correct so your point
has been building I did on that one
thank you but yeah but also I wanted to
make it clear about the difference of
the opinion on the neighborhood plan
between the parish myself and other
representatives and the planners yeah
okay I think I think we've got that
point yeah thank you
um cancer balance touched on it and it's
also in the report and I think it was Mr
Lewis mentioned as well
obviously I'll work with figures all day
so I'm a bit of a stutter when it comes
to this and I think it says 18
objections letters of objection
and third-party responses I think Mr
Lewis mentioned 22 he was representing
is he is not there from Mrs yeah thank
you and then 10 letters of support from
local residents and I think Mrs Johnson
said two Neighbors
supported the application so obviously
okay okay thank you so um yeah no that's
fine yeah thank you I didn't object okay
so there is some support for this
application uh as you've taken into
account those two that didn't make it
yeah I hear what you're saying the
difference is they didn't object they
haven't actively supported that said I
don't want this to go through it because
it opens up the floodgates of his being
targeted across our Conservation Area
for small areas of land to be built on
and totally changed the Dynamics of
Harvey I have in the past had words with
the conservation officer and he's
described it quite well and eloquently
far better words than I can use and I
know what he would say that this would
not be right
okay thank you any more questions for
the ward member okay sir Kendall just
one please chairman
um councilor Harris you were the board
member a couple of years ago weren't you
um you remember the previous application
you've seen this one I don't want to
talk about the previous application
because of course that's not relevant
tonight but do you think anything has
substantially changed
at the moment no I don't thank you
that's all I want to talk to the offices
later as well
well again well I'll put some
calculation I think you're free to go
cancer Harrison again many apologies for
missing you out it wasn't intentional
all right we'll move seamlessly on there
to points of clarification all right
Council Barnes thank you
uh my one of my abilities is all
virtually conservates the area
said 140 hours he's supposed to have 88.
I'm led to believe under the core
strategy
that single dwellings
can be allowed and we don't have any
support or
comments from any conservation architect
unless they're building
so am I correct in saying that
in under the core strategy one
development can be addressed it can be
approved if it's um
designed okay
okay
Jim thank you for that question that's
certainly one of the points that I was
was hoping to bring up I don't know
whether members can remember seeing this
I'm sorry it's not in color
um it was a slide put up by your policy
officer John careford at a training
session some time ago
um
how do I pray to see this it's a slide
put up by John careford at a training
session some time ago it was intended to
address the the exact point that you
raised councilor Barnes the issue of
single dwellings in lsvs if you recall
back when the course strategy was
originally adopted the view was taken
that once an lsv had reached the the
number of dwellings that it was
anticipated to have for the plan period
that that was it it was full and we
shouldn't allow any more and we made
exactly we made a number of decisions
on that basis and the original
application on this site was one of them
that it was inappropriate to allow more
dwellings because the total number for
the village in the plan period had
already been met and we've been told
very very clearly in appeal decisions
since then that that is the wrong
approach and that's why John prepared
this this plan and what he's saying on
this plan is the first test is is the
site within a built up area boundary if
it is move on is it small scale if it is
move on does it respect the character
and integrate well if it does move on is
the scheme high quality design if it is
move on does it comply with all other
policies if it does approve it
irrespective of how many houses have
been allowed in that settlement now I
know there are five tests in there and
it's absolutely right to go through
those five tests and test all of them
and if this application fails one of the
tests then it goes straight to refuse
but it's not being refused because there
are too many houses in the village it's
being refused because it fails one of
those tests
does that answer the question chair
yeah
cancer Kendall thank you I'll come back
to the point where what's changed you're
saying that the infant has changed is
that at several occasions inspectors
have said well you're not taking the
right approach to the numbers so
therefore the house design is
essentially exactly the same you you
talk about your number of texts who's
established whether this is high quality
and why have we not consulted the
conservation officer
thank you
um
high quality is a matter of judgment
your planning officers have assessed it
and evaluated it and come to a
conclusion but it is high quality it's
obviously uh entirely within this
committee's remit to decide that it
isn't and to have good reasons for
making that decision uh you know that
that's that's the way the system works
but officers have made that assessment
the application hasn't been referred to
your conservation officer because uh
conservation office's time is limited
conservation officers spend their
vast majority of their time dealing with
applications on and within the cartilage
of listed buildings most of the time
conservation applications matters
related to conservation are dealt with
by case officers about by their managers
who are at least two of us are
conservation trained I'm conservation
trained I am eligible to work as a
conservation officer as is Karen Tate so
we cover it from our general knowledge
of conservation we have the conservation
officers there to discuss it with if we
need them but we don't need to consult
them because we have adequate skills
already within the team
hence the scientist yeah can I take a
slight issue with uh Mr Barker there he
referred to the chart that John careford
produced as a training exercise I I
don't recall it so I presumably didn't
go on that particular training session
but that that's not the point
experience is this when we were
compiling the local plan which I was
leading on from the members point of
view
we had an inspector with us called Peter
Drew
now Pete Drew was quite adamant that we
should stick to numbers
therefore
The View came amongst members of this
Council and probably some were more
prominent in expressing it than others
but effectively they should be applied
quite rigidly
and therefore we should have no more
than two thousand houses in our space
what actually then happened was that a
number of planning appeals took place
because we were refusing them because
they came outside the rigid
interpretation of those numbers and I
haven't got a specific example I'm just
talking in generalization terms but but
judging from Mr Barker's reaction he
recalls this situation and in fact it
was pleasant it was planning inspectors
that said that we could relax those
rocks that Mr Druid encouraged us to
hold quite firm
so therefore whilst I accept his his
interpretation of Mr Clifford's
diagram that effectively there could be
categories of things that says do it on
single houses I do feel quite strongly
The View we've had tonight from harbury
is another Village at a local service
Ridge in my own wall which is in a very
similar position it's not a category one
it's a category three but that they
still have boundaries and there's a
feeling amongst the residents of great
strength that should be applied to these
numbers that Mr Drew said we should
defend which planning inspectors have
guided us to do otherwise and I know we
hold a lot of weight on planning appeals
and the reports that come from them
um but the situation is this and I think
we do I would argue that we do have to
effectively at time to say repeat the
point that the ward member raised that
we've got a number of Open Spaces in our
conservation areas in Harborough I think
that's what she said and therefore we
want to see them preserved
police that's what the community that
she represents wants to see and I'm
getting nods from over there so I have
got that bit right obviously
um and I think we we do have to give
some weight to that chairman
it's good to see you've got something
right there cancer site so thank you
very much for that I'm sorry I I do need
to come back on that no no
I I I've said all I all I can say on the
subject of numbers I I hear what
counselor saint has to say
um
all I know is that what elevates humans
above animals is
the ability to to think and to change
over time and that's what's happened
things have changed over time
um
as far as the the other point that
councilor
um
councilor Saint was making
the issue of preserving Open Spaces in
the village
absolutely you know if the open space
has such a high value that it should be
preserved
that is a legitimate reason to refuse
the application but you have to set out
what that value is you have to
understand what that value is and
officers have looked at this and they've
looked at the value of the space and
they've looked at the value of this this
new dwelling and they've concluded that
actually it will enhance
the conservation area now I know that
you know people don't agree with
officers on that but that's the
recommendation we're making to you and
if you disagree with that that is
there's entirely your right
to do so providing you can articulate
your reasoning
um chairman there's one other point I I
absolutely must make a counselor said
she's been talking to the portfolio
holder this afternoon and I have made a
commitment to the portfolio holder to to
explain something to you is now a good
time to do it or would you like me to
come back to later stage it's a matter
of of going through the neighborhood
development around policies
I think that's a relevant argument I'm
afraid cancer bonds and I'm I'm happy
for you
absolutely it's it's totally relevant
yeah longer I think if it's totally
relevant and I think we need some
clarification
um
I think let me Jim at any point you feel
I'm I'm drifting off the subject feel
free to stop me okay absolutely okay I
think that's the third point
no what what I've done chair is I've
gone to the neighborhood development
plan this is a I know it's a departure
for us
but I've gone to the development plan
the neighborhood plan
um and this is the first policy that was
referred to policy H1
and it says that new Housing Development
will be concentrated within the harbury
village settlement boundary the site is
within the village settlement boundary
so I I don't think there can be any
dispute that it complies with that
element of the policy
moving on you can see new housing will
be supported where they and then there
are all of those criteria there is seven
criteria
I'm not going to take you through them
in in individual detail unless you wish
to
um but clearly you can see that the the
first category unacceptable adverse
impact on the parish's rural landscape I
think that was raised by the the parish
councilor in its no okay
it's an issue to consider does it have
an unacceptable adverse impact on the
parish's rural landscape or not if it
does and you have reasons why
that's a reason for refusal
second one does it conserve or enhance
the significance of designated and
non-designated Heritage assets does it
conserve or enhance the conservation
area you've heard of you from the
objectors that it doesn't you've seen
the view of officers that it does
that's a discrepancy so and that's the
point where we have to make that funding
committee yes now there is just one
chair that I I really do need to to talk
you through and that Criterion e
do not lead to the inappropriate
development of residential Gardens that
would cost cause harm to the Village by
reason of over development significant
loss of usable Garden spaces for both
existing and proposed new properties and
lots of off-street parking I I don't
know but I I suspect that's the critical
one
from the point of view of the objectors
and I just wanted to talk you through
the way that a planning officer an
inspector or looking at Mesa a solicitor
would approach that section of the
policy because you have to take it apart
you can't leap at these things you have
to take it apart
so
is it inappropriate development of a
residential Garden
well clearly because it says at the
beginning that development will take
place inside the village the vast
majority of the village is residential
Gardens there must be some residential
Garden somewhere that's acceptable for
development so it can't just be all
residential Gardens where it's
inappropriate
so it's got to cause harm to the Village
by reason of over development
well how do you establish that we've
already discussed the garden size was it
50 square meters
and something like that before just six
yeah
I thought it was I thought it was 52.
which exceeds the the garden size
requirement in your emerging
supplementary planning document for a
two-bedroom dwelling so it's not the
garden size in what other way might it
be over development
um
significant loss of usable Garden space
well we've heard from the the applicant
that it was sold separately it isn't
Garden but even if you you category
categorize it as Garden you could see
that a very very large garden is left
for the host dwelling so it's not
resulting in a significant loss of
usable Garden space for the existing
the proposed I've already discussed that
and lots of off-street car parking again
the applicant went through it Alison
went through it in her presentation so
you can see the main criteria that are
set out in this policy are all appear to
be passed
and if it's all passed then the first
part the inappropriate development of
residential Garden must necessarily be
passed you can't just come to the
conclusion that it's inappropriate
development of residential Garden
because it's a residential Garden you've
got to go through all the other stages
does that make sense
I think that makes sense yeah I think
the points we
might have to concentrate on r b
does it conserve or enhance again that's
the committee's decision to make a
judgment on and I think G are
appropriate in terms of size scale
design and respect the character of
surrounding area which I think they
again as we talk about planning peoples
have different opinions on the same
subject so there is some some form of
subjectivity on these opinions so there
is some
oh so far there's plenty of things we
can divide upon so if you've got no
further questions technical questions
for the officers I'm happy to move on to
the debate
I was told I had to bring back was what
is the difference between that those two
the original one that was refused and
the one was we are looking at tonight
um thank you there are a number of
changes
um the roof height has been lowered
previously it was 7.1 meters to the
ridge now it's 6.6 meters
it's set further back from the road
Frontage previously it was 1.6 meters at
um back from in the bottom corner from
the back of the pavement it's now 2.4
meters
they've retained part of the existing
wall along the road Frontage
um they replacing the beach Hedge
the upper back windows are now lower
and the side windows from the
outbuilding are to be filled in
um
and I think this latest application has
now got a bin store and Electric
charging point for cars
so they they have responded although the
changes might not seem enormous in the
context of a small two-bedroom to
Cottage they are they have responded to
the concerns raised previously
Johnson catch the bonds
the bonds well I I live in well I don't
live in welfare but I've got wealth on
my patch the planning officer here knows
that a lady bought a house wanted a
replacement dwell in and she wanted
another house in the garden
we spent months I don't know you didn't
like it
I said months going through what the
design is and the right materials
and in the end we usually get something
that is acceptable because like I said
earlier under the core strategy we can't
stop we've lost on appeal
where we should have you know even the
parish counters support me in the
respect of the type of materials we use
local Stone all that sort of thing so
what we do is negotiate isn't that
correct
right and that is the way forward as far
as I can see some negotiation has gone
ahead if it was in my Village probably
more negotiation but in planning terms
unfortunately I've got 143 houses in 88
Village
in the outer area and in Long Marston
I'm supposed to have 32 I've got 476.
so laugh as you might she's the the
appearance and and the way they look in
my eyes which is the important factor
um well I don't want to slum in my
Village that's what happens when you
keep filling the gardens up but as a
planet officer knows we were very strong
with the applicant we told them what we
wanted we told them what we couldn't
have and we ended up with months and
months and
talking and then in the end she said oh
it does look better doesn't it do you
think that's very annoying so in
planning terms I understand what the the
parish and the board members saying but
in my eyes
um it's it can only be approved
unfortunately
I'll switch to
yeah
thank you chairman I
I'm sorry I disagree I just don't think
this fits properly and I'm I've heard
what what Dale said uh I think well
honestly I think you went a little bit
beyond his remit in terms of advice
there but okay I I've heard what he said
in terms of the neighborhood plan
I I personally agree with what the
neighborhood plant said in the earlier
point I think there's a second Point
down in terms of the impact it will have
on the conservation area so I'm willing
to propose that we refuse the
application I think based solely on the
fact that it will have an adverse impact
on the conservation area I understand
what you're saying about neighborhood
plan
my potential objection can't necessarily
stand so I'll just propose adverse
impact only Conservation Area
well I'll see where I'm coming from as
well um no two points on on the plan
um
yeah please
um that I
oh yeah
um rats
no there's no ruts in this application
anyway whilst we're looking for that um
I would be tending yeah okay thank you
Council Barnes whilst I was looking for
that
um
catch the candle slightly stole my
thunder
um no not a problem
um
I think that
with this application
it doesn't enhance the Conservation Area
I'm concerned about the design
and
yeah
I think it was B it was B in my opinion
I don't think it conserves or enhances
the significance the the Conservation
Area
and
I'm not happy with the
design
and the
um the build of the the materials Etc so
I
um I'm tending to go against officer of
recommendation to Grant on this one
because I don't think it's in keeping
with the Conservation Area
um so I will be supporting
cancer candles proposal was that a
proposal
and I'll be second in The Proposal
um
can I help I think I don't agree that
it's a high quality design and I don't
think it preserves an enhances the
existing Street Scene or the
Conservation Area
I'm sure you can build up a number of uh
the reason from that based on I think
it's cs8 as10
but I think that's where the bulk of our
objections lie
content
I'm sorry to push these members but in
what way isn't it a high quality design
in what way doesn't it enhance uh we
don't feel it is sympathetic to the
existing Street Scene we don't think it
we don't I don't feel it really
complements and I don't think it
enhances the Conservation Area
I I think that's perfectly acceptable in
terms of it's an interpretation for this
committee or I am making on that
application
in the same way that the officers make
the other interpretation
right we've had a proposal and a second
to refuse the application for no reason
for the reasons we've just mentioned
and that was my demand of
um
did you yes you should go first didn't
you what's that have we got a second
there for your theory is supposed to ask
if somebody would secondly I don't
may not be anybody
support that ending as a proposal there
can you can we just clarify with it
Council Barnes are you making a proposal
to I did make a proposal that as far as
I was concerned
it'll be okay it wouldn't it didn't come
out but
so you're proposing so there's a like
the opposite recommendation halfway a
secondary fill up proposal cancer
Fielding
so we've got a proposal to Grant the
application secondly about cancel the
building all those in favor of The
Proposal
against
second
we've had to say well we've already got
a proposed on the second
we've had a proposal and a second uh by
myself and councilor Kendall to refuse
the application
all those in favor
those against
abstentions
committee resolves to refuse application
1803136 if you oh chairman detail
wording to be agreed with you tomorrow
but that was just took the words right
out of my mouth now so thank you
for the next few days the next few days
yeah
right we'll move on to our next item
last item on the agenda which is 18
slash
zero three three one six slash vermi 8
device line Harvey lemington Spa
variation of condition two
Etc
and again Allison will be presenting
this application
right
thank you Anson
this application is a section 73
variation of conditions application
which seeks to vary a 2014 planning
permission which granted
for the demolition of a former garage
office and the erection of three
dwellings in its place the properties
have been built and are now occupied
the application seeks to vary three
conditions to do with the approved plan
numbers hard and soft landscaping and
details of the hard Landscaping
so first slide shows the position of the
application site within the village of
harbury as you can see the site lies
within the Eastern side of the village
but comfortably within the built-up area
boundary
the site lies outside but near to the
Village consolation area
on this slide
the left-hand plan shows the 2014
approval
the right hands plan shows the current
proposal
three houses one detached and a
semi-detached pair with Gardens to the
rear and a car park to the South
so this is the car parking area
semi-detached
detached and Gardens to the rear
the relative Gardens and parking spaces
are highlighted in green and blue
and so each individual house is Gardens
and the car parking spaces are outlined
as shown
there's a slight increase in the garden
sizes in this proposal
this slide shows the external variations
both applications make provision for six
car parking spaces
a boundary fence has already been
erected to the north side of the car
Park area
which is
here
as this results in parking spaces to the
left of the picture being slightly too
narrow and not in line with the minimum
size standards as outlined in the SPD
the developers agreed to reposition the
fence by stepping it in to make the
parking area approximately one meter
wider
so the fence line would be repositioned
up here
this would allow sufficient space for
six vehicles to park within the car park
the committee update recommends
the repositioning of the fence is
controlled by condition to take place
within three months should be permission
be forthcoming
so there's rear access from the car park
to the rear of the houses from this
point
the 2014 scheme contained a rear path
leading from the car park to the rear of
each of the three properties so all the
way across
the pose scheme contains a shortened
rear path which only serves the middle
property
so from here to here
the southernmost property has its own
gate to the rear Garden along along its
side boundary adjacent to the house
here
the detached property
this one
does not benefit from a rare pathway any
longer instead the occupants have to
walk from the car park around the front
of the three three properties to access
their property
so from the car park around the pavement
into their house it's about 50 meters
in terms of the garden sizes the
proposed scheme would result in a slight
increase to the current Garden sizes
of the Southern
property
as a result of the shorter rear pathway
the middle plot would benefit from a
larger Garden area
that's here
and the garden size of the detached
property is roughly similar to the
previous scheme
the current application proposes
additional soft Landscaping to the site
which will be controlled by condition
the original 2014 approval contained
more planting to the rear boundary
belong here
which included several trees
this has not been implemented
instead alternative planting of shrubs
is proposed in a bed along here
the planting to the rear boundary
would have been severely limited by
space any trees planted in this area
would have potentially overhung both the
gardens and the neighboring Gardens and
the pathway
so the approved planting within the
garden space of the detached proper
property up here in this corner has not
been implemented implemented although
limited alternative planting is now
proposed along the rear boundary in
this area
there's a change to the northern
boundary wall along here
the northern low boundary wall
with originally had a gate set opposite
the doorway
here
this has not been built instead of
continuous section of stone wall aligns
with the side of the dwelling and the
gate is positioned five meters to the
West so that's here
so this slide shows a real real
elevation of the 2014 scheme previously
showed two sets of patio doors here
and the new scheme now contains one
patio door and one window instead
so slight changes to the internal layout
this side the is the approved scheme
this is the proposed scheme
on the ground floor
it's now slightly more open plan and
includes the repositioning of the
staircase
and on the first floor the originally
approved 2014 application showed each
property to have two bedrooms
the current plan shows the master
bedroom to have been subdivided
to form a smaller bedroom with an
adjacent dressing room which could be
used as a third bedroom
point to note is the draft parking
standards require two parking spaces for
both a two or three bedroom property
so next few slides show
some elevations of the existing building
so the
semi-detached detached existing parking
area
open Green Space to the front
the side elevation of the detached house
showing the new stone wall and the
access gate
um that's the car parking space for six
cars to the South
the view of the car parking area
the end of my presentation
Mr chairman the recommendation is to
approve the application for the reasons
detailed on the report subject to the
updates
thank you Allison we'll move to our
first Speaker Council lockley again
long time don't see
yeah
um yeah would you mind putting up the
um the plan the first one not that one
that one yeah thank you
okay
um yes the Parish council's main
objection is about parking and about
access to the northernmost detached
property so this new scheme eliminates
the footpath from the car parking area
to this property and as Alison aligned
to us the residents of that property
would be expected to park in that car
park and walk all the way around
to their property in reality that
doesn't happen in reality what happens
is that the people park on the pavement
or on the streets and they're right
opposite even though you can't really
see it on that plan they're right
opposite a junction and that is
something that has been ongoing since
this house was built and it's been
exacerbated by the absence of this path
so the residents cannot use this car
park
and easily access their property and
that's been contrary obviously to the
design that was approved by Stratford
and that's why we're objecting it should
be noted that the green space that's uh
to the right of the property is public
land so that's not there
it's not within their cartilage that is
I think it's owned by Stratford actually
it's not owned by a parish but I think
we maybe cut the grass
so that is the essence of our objection
is about traffic really and parking
thank you any questions
the road you'll say that people Park are
near the junction yes
um
irrespectively if look the houses were
that has people popped there in the past
no because that was it was it was a it
was a garage and it had a big big four
core area to park in and you can sit on
that plan actually
um directly to the north is the junction
and so they Park on that opposite that
Junction that road Junction and that's
where the cars are parked because that
obviously provides the easiest access to
those properties
okay and is it I think Allison said it's
an extra 50 meters talk
I haven't measured it but that sounds
about right okay because they have to
walk all the way around the Green Space
to get there thank you very much
we have Linda richly
and I believe from the harbor Society
society that will do and the local
residents
and we've got three minutes three
minutes right you have my apologies I am
re wearing red because I am still
extremely angry about the incompetence
that has followed through the whole of
the applications on this site
um your officers is minded to approve
the amendments to the problems that we
highlighted to you at the outset you
didn't take local knowledge into account
and what is followed on is all your
fault
um the buildings weren't built to the
plans approved so that in the here and
now we have illegal parking as Tim has
said because the car park is inadequate
the bins left out on the green and the
verges because the garden space is so
tiny the prospect of further car parking
problems
um will occur because although we told
you again initially that there was room
for three bedrooms in each of these
three houses so that's potentially
that's I can't do it uh three twos are
six times three is
18 people 18 cars
loss of the part of the green we believe
that this wasn't built as to the plans
we think we're fairly certain having
looked on Google you can look at the
original building that was there and you
can look at what was built and you will
see that it is encroached onto the green
which I believe you own and you have not
received payment for
um
this building intrudes into the views of
the conservation area and the church the
minuscule Garden space is far smaller
than ever the plan shown and it's
resulted in the waste bins being left
out completely left on the greens left
in the verges and it can't be pleasant
for those people who are renting they
have no space for the washing in these
tiny little Gardens and nothing for
recreation The Villages have been left
with ugly intrusive building we can't
provide sufficient space for the
occupiers or their vehicles it's caused
considerable inconvenience to immediate
neighbors it's reduced the size of the
green it's the only play area for the
local children and because of the lack
of parking vehicles are dangerously
parked on our verges and at that
Junction I've sent the officer pictures
of these and their hazards to other Road
users I understand that whoever owns the
Green is liable and could be surcharged
um I don't know what you do about it
basically the only thing to do is knock
it down and start again but you're not
going to do that I would be very
interested to know what you can do to
deal with the the
things that were omitted the things that
have been done that shouldn't have been
done and why
action wasn't taken much earlier because
during the build we kept asking for
people to come out and look at it and as
far as I know nothing was done
any questions
I'm sorry is it this is originally or
how would you like to be addressed is it
Mrs regime I'm Linda Linda thank you any
questions for Linda don't go yet
nope right
um
I've got one question you mentioned the
green area yes and I how do I switch
this down
um just you know speaking very quickly
and I know you're trying to get all your
points no it's it's the anger I'm sorry
I did try to calm yeah no problem I can
fully understand people do get
passionate about planning applications
so
as well so yes I live in southam so it's
just as far yeah anyway
um you said about the Green Space open
air play area and I didn't quite catch
what you're saying could you just
clarify that point yes
um one of the objectives paid for a
professional survey of the site because
we were of the opinion that what was
proposed couldn't be fitted on the site
and that's proved to be true
um
it brought up things like
the fact that they would encroach on the
green the fact that there was space for
a third bedroom it brought out all of
these things that and more that you've
tried to take enforcement on
um that's why people are so very very
angry but yes it looks if you look on
Google you can see the original outline
of the building you look
sorry you're up further back in Google
you can go back in history if you you
compare the two you'll see
cut me off you can see that you can draw
a straight line and it attends just on
the edge of the three uh cottages on the
other part of Dove House Lane if you
then look at how it is now it goes two
Cottages down so there's a chunk of the
green there's been a path put across the
group there's been a part put across the
green which certainly wasn't on the
plans
um probably to encourage people to walk
along there as they can't walk through
the gardens is that okay that's fine
thank you and if there are some
enforcement issues we've got fine
Offices here yeah I know I take them
around we've noted your comments I said
we will take those on board thank you
okay thank you thank you Linda
right
um I believe the applicants no longer
want to speak is that is all right
gentlemen
so we can now move on to our next
speaker which is councilor Harris and I
haven't forgotten you this time against
the house
I'm going to speak about this this
evening but I will just have a quick say
you don't have to if you don't want no I
do I think it's important that I
let you know that Harvey Parish Council
a very thorough thoughtful and pragmatic
in their approach to planning and I
usually support most of their views so
I'll be standing behind uh Mr lockley's
view tonight in objecting
thank you any questions to order number
no
good good points of clarification to the
officers any points of qualification
chairman I'm reading on page 78.
WCC highways
it then says no objection
except they then go on to talk about
Works necessary on the highway to form
the access
that needs to be up to Highway Authority
standards
can we inquire about progress with that
but equally I'd like to ask if the
required six spaces are in line with I
think it's part o of the development
requirements SPD
and we refer to other parts of that
earlier on today
so are the six spaces adequate for this
size of development because quite
clearly they've got to squeeze whatever
they need onto this particular site
there's no I'm in room for anything else
the parking spaces as shown on the plan
are 2.4 meters wide by 4.8 meters long
which is slightly less than the new
parking standards in part o
which are
five meters by 2.5
with respect to Allison that's not the
question I asked I'm referring to the
actual quantity of parking spaces is six
sufficient I've got a feeling it might
not be
Allison to be fair today to mention that
in a presentation she did touch on the
fact it was for the size of the
properties two to three bedrooms but I
will let Allison answer for herself
um yes there's two parking spaces
allocated for each house and each two
bedroomed all three bedroomed house is
required to have two parking spaces
and the second part was the progress on
the highways
on the highways objection
um page 78
to do with the
uh the works on the highways to form the
access needed to be it's not an
objection chairman it's a qualification
and The Works to form that exists need
to be to a highway
um
the the access has already been
constructed
um this application to vary the plans
has come in and highways were consulted
on
the scheme and they would have visited
the site and seen the
the
scheme as it now is
um and if they had had any concerns they
would have raised them then as a new
objection
this implies that there were concerns
chairman what we've got on our papers on
page 78
in the 10th of December which is what
two and a half months ago so
um
we might have actually expected to some
work to have been done
you say something about
sorry Council the saint I didn't hear
the last couple of sentences you said
could you repeat them please
yes what I've said is
that the WCC highways have referred to
these works on the 10th of December
which is two and a half months ago
and therefore we call it might have
expected some work to be done but what
are we saying that this is all can or
will or what be done
what we're saying chairman is that
there's no objection from the highway
Authority and if the highway Authority
require any Works to be done they have
their own powers to do it it would be
inappropriate for us to try to do their
job
Council Philly
the comment made by the the parish and
is the problem associated with people
walking up from the south to the north
of the site is there not room on the
North side to put in a carport there or
is it is it too cramped to actually make
access for a couple of vehicles
chairman we have an application in front
of us which we need to decide
so it's not part of the application
cancel Fielding
any further questions should we move on
to the debate
well it looks to me if people are lazy
they'll put on weight if they're Fit and
Well they're back in the right place
um I can't really see with the County
Council and parking there is enough
parking spaces there there is a bit of a
problem but it's not our place to
resolve it so as far as I'm concerned I
can go along or propose the opposite's
recommendation
said I completely understand uh what
Linda said and I think she's got a very
good point it's an ugly development but
I feel we've thought that bad when it's
been lost already it's not that I don't
have sympathy for the parish and for you
Linda as well but it's been done we are
where we are I second the proposal
the debate we've had a proposer and a
seconder that the application is granted
all those in favor
committee results again application
1803316
could we uh could we ask the officers to
look at what these ladies can concerns
are about what hasn't and could refer to
the enforcements I have a commitment
okay uh no
this condition s
there's no any other business so oh
urgent business I will close the meeting
thank you